[Music]
[Applause]
understand Al Michaels the Hall of Famer
joining us on the program Al how you
feeling
uh speaking of bad backs not bad though
but I'm gonna Tee It Up in about an hour
and a half with Mr Jim Nance who is out
here or the Genesis yes sir so Nance is
going to play golf
today right and I'm gonna I'm thinking
about what you told me Johnny Miller but
I'm on the Range the other day and
somebody gave me six syllables right not
four so now I'm all screwed up no keep
it simple
I'd like to but I have like 837 swing
thoughts
the only one that works is please God
Don't Let Me Whip yeah but have you
whiffed before
no but I when I played in the ATT back
in 2008 I couldn't feel my body five
thousand people are aligning the Fairway
and that's all I can think about please
God Please Don't Let Me Whip and here
you are you've done all of these major
events Olympics and World Series and
Super Bowl but if I said the most
nerve-wracking thing that you've ever
been a part of
ATT Pebble Beach Pro-Am is up there
because they think you're good and you
don't want to take somebody out with a
you know a shot down the Third Base Line
not only up there it's on top of the
pyramid Dan yeah not even there's
nothing even close to the way I felt
on the First Tee at Pebble Beach not
only are you thinking about killing
somebody but it's just embarrassing
yourself or hitting like a a yard and
then you have to take a fairway wood I
mean I'm thinking just get me out of
here get please God so I hit like 140
yard ground ball down the Third Base
Line and got the hell out of there
all you want to do is make sure that
your first tee shot
is great and the last putt you make on
18th that's all you care about when you
play in these pro-ams
by the time I got to 18 nobody's there
and nobody cares
um what you think of the Super Bowl
hell of a game great game you know again
it gets I don't want to say determined
on one play everybody's saying what you
think of the coal I mean we've seen that
play a thousand times it's a 50 50 calm
the one thing that I felt was um
I I saw some columns and uh some other
uh people talking about the fact you
know you can't let a game in that way to
me I think Justice should be blind I
think if it's if it's passion
interference on the first play of the
game or the last Lady it's the same
thing yeah so they called they saw I
thought Bradbury was very classy saying
that um he was hoping uh they would let
it go but they didn't but it was a it
was a great game you know it it had a
lot of hype uh you had the two best
teams during the regular season and to
the postseason to that point so uh yeah
and that's that's why we love football
games like that and players just want
consistency if you're going to call that
in the first quarter then they're going
to call that in the fourth quarter and I
think Bradbury may have been under the
impression they're going to let me
they're going to let us play because
they weren't calling holding throughout
the game maybe I I don't know but uh
yeah but it was it was a great game very
entertaining obviously uh we love having
you on but uh we also uh wanted to have
you reminisce on Tim mccar however he
replaced Howard Cosell in 1985 and your
thoughts when I mean talk about
different personalities to ex you know
exchange one another in the booth what
were you thinking when Tim McCarver came
into the booth for Howard number one
number one I loved Tim loved him Hall of
Fame human being Dan
um so when Kim retired from uh the field
from playing he did some I had done a
few games with him in those years we
were mixing and matching around the
clock and every week with somebody
different we had Don Drysdale or a
Weaver had retired for a couple years I
had Earl I had thiefs I broke Steve
Stone in who's now had a 40-year career
uh and Tim and Jim Palmer were doing a
lot of games and Jim had then retired at
that point so he was full time with us
so going into the 85 World Series
we were alternating postseason with NBC
so they had the playoffs it was our Our
World Series and Howard at that point
Coastal had become uh cantankerous to
use a word that he'd love to use all the
time and bitter and he would pretty much
cast the poll over the entire crew
because he didn't want to be there and
you know we didn't want him to be there
and then about a week before the season
ended he wrote his second book called I
never played the game and in the book he
trashed everybody at ABC including roon
orange who had given him the job and had
let him have free reign all of those
years so when that came out uh
at ABC they were talking about what what
are you going to do now you're going to
put this guy on the air who's angry and
bitter blah blah blah blah blah
so I get a call from one of the ABC
Executives during the playoffs which are
on NBC at that point and he tells me
uh were replaced in Cosell with Tim
McCarver that was one of the greatest
phone calls I've ever had in my life and
Tim and Jim and I wound up doing the
dance in the 85 World Series uh 87 World
Series the 89 World Series which was the
earthquake and then we shared the 95
World Series with NBC with something
called the [__] and maybe Baseball
Network
um but Tim you know it's so funny I
think of so many things with Tim one of
them of course would be
in the earthquake World Series in 1989
we come on the air at five o'clock we're
doing the stream set
the Earth shakes at 504 but I had led to
Tim we're on camera and then Tim is
narrating uh and dissecting a play that
had taken place two nights before in
game two and open and all of a sudden I
blurred out we're having an earthquake
and Tim put a death grip on my leg and
Tim would always say that you know I I
grabbed his leg I said I have this I
have the scars to prove it I have been
through earthquakes before you haven't
but I had a all I can let me put it to
you this way Dan three-person booths are
tough you know that it's very tough uh
and I've been I've had a few of them in
my career uh this was one where I have
to say that the three of us together
Palmer and McCarver and myself we were I
think better as a threesome than any
combination of the two of us so I loved
it I treasure the memories I had with
with Jim and with Tim because they were
so into making The Telecast as great as
it could be they were great men and uh
you know you had Palmer who knows
everything about pitching obviously and
Timmy who knew everything about
everything as a catcher or played for
four different decades so he he saw
everything and the one thing that I was
certainly convinced of during those
years Dan if he had become a manager
he'd have been a great manager and he
had opportunities to do that but he just
preferred broadcasting yeah I wondered
about that because you know we we Marvel
at Tony Romo or at least we have where
he's predicting something that would
happen Tim would tell you what he
thought was going to happen a long time
ago that he was so ahead of every other
analyst it felt like that he was playing
the game while broadcasting the game and
saw it in a unique way
very much so uh he was able to do that
he was also able to bring up certain
things
that you'd never had thought about and I
mean I knew a lot about baseball at that
point because I've been with the Reds as
you know you were listening to me when
you know you were in your bassinet and
I'm doing the Cincinnati Reds and you
know I've been with Sparky Anderson and
Pete Rose and Johnny Bench I had a PhD
in baseball and then I started working
with Tim and he would bring things up to
myself wow nobody talks about these
things it's so true and he made it so
interesting and he loved the game and he
loved teaching the game to people I
would say uh in when I think back
through my career I had John Madden who
of course taught uh millions of people
to love football more than they did and
to understand football I would put my
Carver in that category with baseball I
think Timmy taught as much baseball to
millions of people as John Madden did
football to the millions of people who
love John but then do you allow a little
more room for Madden and McCarver be at
your role as play by play voice does it
change in accordance to who your analyst
is
it does and with both of those guys and
and so I'm not uh saying that
everybody's the same but these guys were
at the top of at least Mike Kerman the
great thing about maccarver so in my the
way I do play-by-play and you've heard
me for years I incorporate a lot of the
fundament fundamental or rudimentary
analysis inside my play-by-play now I've
worked with some people who don't want
that because I'm saying what they wanted
to say and if you know what I mean in
other words I'll tell you know I don't
have to give you the you know the uh
just the basics but I will tell what I
will do is give you a launching pad with
McCarver especially and I said to Tim
one day I said listen am I taking up too
much of your space he says no no no no
you keep doing what you're doing because
you're you're forcing me to go to a
different area where I feel like I'm
energized and I can bring up certain
things that normally I would that bring
up because I would do the rudimentary of
fundamental analysis so he loved it and
I loved working with him because boy you
let him go and you don't know where he
was going to go but you would learn you
would learn and appreciate what he was
talking about yeah I grew up with Tony
kubeck when he was doing it I thought
Tony was spectacular and I did too I
mean and very underrated as as a an
analyst and then when Tim came in it's
almost like oh my God this is so unique
and then all of a sudden like the
audience gets tired it feels like after
a while they're like oh he's a
know-it-all and I I but but in the
beginning it's like oh this is great he
knows it all and he's sharing it and
then it felt like that going oh here's
Tim going to say I'll tell you and it it
I don't know it just feels like maybe
that's what's going on with Tony Romo
like yeah that's okay now we want to
hear something else
I I don't know look it's it's difficult
and you know at least with with Tim he
was only on once a week if to me it's
amazing that you know especially when he
took like the Mets job and he was with
the Yankees he did the Giants for a
while he did a bunch of cardinal games
if you're on every night that's really
tough to bring up new stuff every night
yeah but on National Television once a
week Tim was able to do that but believe
me I would sit there next to Tim and go
damn you know I've seen a couple of
thousand baseball games I never thought
about that and you know and just I mean
look he was just a wonderful man he was
courteous uh just the way he treated
people I mean I love the guy he was he
was he was fantastic just loved the man
he's Al Michaels the Hall of Fame
broadcaster getting ready to go Tee It
Up with Jim Nance uh handicap wise how
many shots is Nance giving you
well we were Partners yesterday
and we went down uh down the tubes we we
lost I think 40 bucks whatever it was
okay so today you know Jim and I we were
we're Brethren so um you know whatever
our handicapped Jim's pretty good these
guys you got to tell you you know I
played with Jim for a long time but he's
got that Johnny Miller yeah my problem
is you know I went to those xco clubs
which are very light and they're very
good but I can't hit the wall more than
you know 150 yards so Danny what am I
going to do
what do I do I go to the stretch signs
or go to the Pinnacles don't tell me
something tell me anything
and I'm left-handed playing right-handed
job I mean let's yeah I feel like you're
my shrink right now
and and you play on hey you play on a
great Golf Course Bel Air is a wonderful
goal no question yeah no question yeah
beautiful and I tell them that soon
I don't know when I'm coming out but I I
did tell people Riviera is so pretty but
it's it's pretty hard too like certain
courses you go God that looks so much
fun and then you get out there and
you're like damn this is a difficult
course I played in the Pro and the other
day I teed off at 7 50. it was 42
degrees and the wind was 40 miles an
hour in the Pro Am
I went home and I slept for three hours
it was a lot of fun though played with
the JT posting young pro he's won a
couple of tournaments good guy really
good guy uh well good luck today
well thank you Dan yeah good luck today
you won't be there Monday but I'll
report it in anyway yeah tell hello Jim
Hello friends that we said yeah thank
you Al
take care daddy be good man that's uh Al
Michaels reminiscing about Tim McCarver
who passed away yesterday at the age of
81.